could you take a step back and I
apologize if it's a ridiculous question
but what is suffering if you were try to
define what suffering is how would you
go about it
suffering is a conscious state they can
be no suffering for a being who is
completely unconscious and it's
distinguished from other conscious
states in terms of being one that
considered just in itself we would
rather be with that it's a conscious
state that we want to stop if we're
experiencing or we want to avoid having
again if we've experienced it in the
past and that's as I say emphasized for
its own sake because of course people
will say well suffering strengthens the
spirit it has good consequences and
sometimes it does have those
consequences and of course sometimes we
might undergo suffering we set ourselves
a challenge to run a marathon or climb a
mountain or even just to go to the
dentist so that the toothache doesn't
get worse
even though we know the dentist is going
to hurt us to some extent so I'm not
saying that we never choose suffering
but I am saying that other things being
equal we would rather not be in that
state of consciousness is the ultimate
goal sort of you have the new ten year
anniversary release the life you can
save book really influential book we'll
talk about it a bunch of times
throughout this conversation but do you
think it's possible to eradicate
suffering errors at the goal or do we
want to achieve a like a kind of minimum
threshold of suffering and then keeping
a little drop of poison that to keep
things interesting in the world in
practice I don't think we ever will
eliminate suffering so I think that
little drop of poison as you put it or
if you like that the contrasting dash of
an unpleasant color perhaps something
like that in in a otherwise harmonious
and beautiful composition that is going
to always be there
if you ask me whether in theory if we
could get rid of it we should I think
the answer is whether in fact we would
be better off or whether in terms of by
eliminating the suffering we would also
eliminate some of the highs the positive
hires and if that's so then we might be
prepared to say it's worth having a
minimum of suffering in order to have
the best possible experiences as well is
there a relative aspect to suffering so
we when you talk about eradicating
poverty in the world is this the more
you succeed the more the bar of what
defines poverty raises or is there at
the basic human ethical level a bar
that's absolute that once you get above
it then it we can morally converge to
feeling like we have eradicated poverty
I think they're both and I think this is
true for poverty as well as suffering
there's an objective level of suffering
or of poverty where we're talking about
objective indicators like you're
constantly hungry you don't you can't
get enough food you're constantly cold
you can't get warm you have some
physical pains that you're never rid of
I think those things are objective but
it may also be true that if you do get
rid of that and you get to the stage
where all of those basic needs have been
met there may still be there new forms
of suffering that develop and perhaps
that's what we're seeing in the affluent
societies we have that people get bored
for example they don't need to spend so
many hours a day earning money to get
enough to eat and shelter so now they're
bored they like a sense of purpose that
can happen and that then is a kind of a
relative suffering this is distinct from
the objective forms of suffering but in
your focus on eradicating suffering you
don't think about that kind
the the kind of interesting challenges
and suffering that emerges in affluent
societies that's just not in your
ethical philosophical brain is that of
interest at all it would be of interest
to me if we had eliminated all of the
objective forms of suffering which I
think of as generally more severe and
also perhaps easier at this stage anyway
to know how to eliminate so yes in some
future state when we've eliminated those
objective forms of suffering I would be
interested in trying to eliminate the
relative forms as well well that's not a
practical need for me at the moment
sorry to linger on it because he kind of
said it but just the is elimination the
goal for the affluent society so is
there a crew you know do you see as
suffering as a creative force suffering
can be a creative force
I think repeating what I said about the
highs and whether we need some of the
lows to experience the highs so it may
be that suffering makes us more creative
and we regard that as worthwhile maybe
that that brings some of those highs
with it that we would not have had if
we'd had no suffering I I don't really
know many people have suggested that and
I certainly can't have no basis for
denying it and if it's true then I would
not want to eliminate suffering
completely but the focus is on and the
absolute not to be cold not to be hungry
yes that's at the present stage of where
the world's population is that's that's
the focus
you